a private lunch with McCraw I sat in as
did Larry for the last 15 or 20 minutes
very important on both economic issues
and national security issues this
morning we had three bilats with Japan
the president Inaba just made an
announcement with an ambassador of light
hyzer on a major trade agreement with
Japan this is a very big deal for
e-commerce and agriculture it's going to
really help beef corn other agricultural
sales we had a very productive meeting
with Canada were expecting that the u.s.
MCA will get passed in the next month or
two and and I was in the economics and
trade meeting this morning two hours you
know what the vibes were good there are
always disagreements you know you've got
high-powered leaders here and there may
be tactical disagreements but every
single one of them I'm going to say this
again every single one of those leaders
agreed that sums got to be done with
China's unfair trading practices every
single one expressed support on that
very key point so I'm just saying the
contentiousness and the arguments that
some people were writing about 24 40
hours ago are not happening
[Music]
well again different people may have
different views on on tariffs and how
we're executing but we had a terrific
meeting with Boris Johnson this morning
he couldn't have been more supportive on
there are issues with China he supports
us on these issues with China and by the
way we're expecting a terrific US UK
trade agreement this is something
ambassador light hyzer and his
counterpart are going to start working
on and we expect to be able do a lot
more business with the UK just making it
Boris Johnson's a free trader and
express that view I am a free trader I
believe my secretary is a free trader
also president Trump has said free and
fair reciprocal trade there you go tell
him the president proposed that yes
bring the three zeros surface and
something I wrote a year ago and wrote
it again sad
president repeated it today his vision
here is zero tariffs zero non-tariff
barriers and zero subsidies and so when
a Boris Johnson and others say they're
free traders the President believes that
two free fair and and reciprocal trade
so I know you're trying to find a little
bit of room a disagreement with the
thing but I didn't hear any ill of a
trade war sometimes you know sometimes
you gotta take some speakers we don't
have free trade with them that's why so
we do not have free trade it's a one-way
street they have free entrance into our
markets our investments our companies
and we do not have the same thing there
that's the only reason why we are in
this situation with China and China
would agree to a fair and balanced
relationship we would sign that deal on
the side that there was a lively
discussion about whether Russia should
be readmitted to the g7 he didn't want
to say who's sided with him but could
you tell us a little bit more about that
conversation and how likely it is that
they'll be invited to the g7 next year I
guess I'd make it the g8 in the United
States but I wasn't in that discussion
so I can't say literally what happened
in it I can tell you the president has
not made any decision one way or another
about next year you know my
understanding and speaking to the
president there's a lot of reasons why
he thinking it would be important to
have Russia sitting here there are areas
of the world that we have shared
interests that are important they're
obviously a big nuclear power we're
interested in in other arms controlled
with them but their issues wide perhaps
we don't want them at the table so the
president hasn't made any decision they
have some sideline meetings the g7 who's
the president welcome
the president has said before that
extent Iran wants to sit down and
negotiate he would not set preconditions
to those negotiations I'm not going to
make any more comments about who's here
and who's not here and what
conversations may or may not be going on
mr. secretary
national emergency I understand he
hasn't yet declared a national emergency
he could declare a national emergency
I'm not going to go into the legal
arguments because we're not yet doing it
so if he decides how would that again
I'm not going to speculate about that he
does have those authorities if for
whatever reason he decides in the future
to use those will clarify exactly how he
uses them and oh there's nothing wrong
by May his the president has exhorted
this to businesses and so we have so
many private meetings with businesses
with POTUS Stephen does I do come home
come home to America we got the best tax
system we got the best regulatory system
it's technology the best technology in
the world we have dance technology way
had it come home that's what the
president said not to come home he
ordered them to look again I want to be
clear before this I've heard to lots of
companies who are already looking
there's lots of companies that have
already moved back to the u.s. back to
other places so yes we've already seen a
lot of mr. secretary and asked me to
clarify does the president have second
thoughts or did he miss here the
question does he have second thoughts
and believe the tariffs should be higher
or did he did he not again again he
doesn't have second thoughts about what
he's done if anything he wanted to
clarify if he had second thoughts it
would be to raise the tariff that
something's really on the table not at
the moment but it's always it not at the
moment okay but if China retaliates
again that's obviously an option the
president the bush in the bush
administration the bush administration
had some tariff sunshine
take them off after a period of time
because it was really beginning
beginning to hurt American business
what's different between then and now
and it's believed by many people that
the US could win a war of attrition
against China but at what cost
again we have not seen any significant
cost to US business at this point I just
clarified the the tariffs that we did
postpone for holiday I want to be very
clear the only reason we did that is
because companies had already committed
in u.s. dollars to those holiday things
so that was the only reason we did that
we have not seen an impact we do have a
exclusion process that ambassador light
Heiser
is is running so to the extent there are
some unique circumstances we have not
seen any inflation the US consumers in
good job really take off thank you